la manifestación para conmemorar el día
internacional del trabajo en París
culminó aquí en la Plaza de la nación de
una forma similar a su inicio en la
Plaza de la República con
enfrentamientos violentos entre
individuos radicalizados y agentes del
orden acciones que llegaron al límite de
lanzar cócteles Molotov contra agentes
de la policía uno de ellos en este
momento permanece herido por quemaduras
hemos también apreciado a lo largo de
nuestro recorrido degradaciones como
aquí en esta parada de autobús pero
también agencias bancarias que han
recibido impactos de proyectiles por
parte de los manifestantes e incendios
que han requerido la acción de urgencia
de los cuerpos de bomberos es esta la
cara digamos visible de la manifestación
que opaca ese llamado Pacífico de los
sindicatos al cual acudieron más de
700.000 personas en todo el país
superando las expectativas de los
propios sindicatos nosotros conversamos
con algunas de esas personas que nos
comentaron lo siguiente digamos que ese
gobierno está destru el sistema social
que los franceses han ido construyendo
décadas tras décadas y pues me parece
importante que que la gente trabajadora
que también tiene sus derechos
está aquí para reivindicar sus derechos
por primero con la de farmacia pensiones
que es un lagusta que hace a plenarle el
bazo por la reacción de macron es desde
7 años por ejemplo Que no escuchan el
pueblo que hace lo que quería y que no
se puede pasar como
aquí la polémica en cuanto a las reforma
de pensiones el principal reclamo de
esta jornada continuará desde el punto
de vista legal y legislativo el próximo
miércoles el consejo constitucional
deberá decidir si valida o no esa
propuesta de referéndum de iniciativa
compartida y luego en junio otro grupo
parlamentario propondrá a la asamblea
nacional una nueva ley que podría
derogar
la reforma de pensiones del presidente
Emmanuel macron ambas iniciativas con
muy pocas posibilidades de éxito